kaka est maintenant je sais pas si vous
le connaissez christine quelqu'un qui
est un petit peu l'agitateur gay numéro
un aujourd'hui qui est sans doute le
dernier écrivain maudit c'est guillaume
dustan
guillaume du store bonsoir bonsoir j'ai
publié mon public qui s'appelle nicolas
pages voilà qui est chez balland c'est
mon livre et j'ai bien le cuivre berger
ici devenir moi ça m'a bouleversé
j'ai mis deux heures avant de m'endormir
déjà et j'ai fait des cauchemars toute
la nuit
enfin ça m'a bouleversé j'ai pas dit
choqué je leur ai passé un truc
et là je changerais réagir ça finira
crapaud guillaume dustan vous avez donc
sans en commun avec christine boutin de
baiser sans capote mais vous la
différence et vous êtes séropositif
quand même c'est quel malheur enfin
c'est pas un peu dangereux non c'est pas
un peu du cyril collard awanou moi je
fais ça qu'avec des gens qui qu'ils sont
aussi on sait aussi un pentagramme en
fait ils ont fait entre nous donc on
fait de mal à personne - comme vous
disiez dans un de vos livres vous
vautrer dans le foot rempoissonner qua
non non je me vautre non je me vautre
cheminots ont été le guide qui peut
pleurer un ca voulons sérieusement fait
de groupes non sur le site en écoute
avec un terreau fausse si je veux dire
c'est pas vrai qu'on meurt du sida enfin
moi vraiment je pense que c'est pas vrai
je pense qu'on fait très peur aux gens
avec une maladie sexuellement
transmissible et que sa ré dit tout la
peur du sexe qu'on leur inculque depuis
qu'ils sont tout petits la haine du
corps qu'on leur inculque depuis qu'ils
sont tout petits
enfin guillaume vous n'êtes pas mort
parce que la trithérapie vous savez bien
moelleuse plein de copains c'est pas
vrai qu'ils sont morts du sida
moi j'en ai je ne sais pas
moi je suis moi je sais bien que je suis
sous bithérapie depuis quinze jours que
sinon ça fait neuf ans que je prends
rien et que je pense que c'est parce que
je me laisse pas avoir par les discours
de peur ouais penser que c'est dans la
tête vous je pense que si on va bien
dans sa tête on meurt pas j'arrête
continue la peste au moyen âge il ya
plein de gens qui sont pas morts bon
faut être très en forme
un nom mais s'il faut être très en
accord avec soi-même faut être très bien
que son entourage faut être très faut
être très heureux faut être très moral
et tout ça à ce moment là on est quand
même très résistant c'est la vie qui
nous les gens vous êtes heureux ça
commence mais ça change
est ce que finalement l'hypersexualité
chez vous est pas devenu un petit peu
commune comme une drogue
si vous n'êtes pas un sexe junkie ccssl
message est dit que ce l'était je suis
plus parce que maintenant je vais mieux
mais c'est sûr que c'était une drogue
mais j'en ai pris plein les drogues mais
moi j'avais très très très rare à mal
les gens qui vont très mal vous êtes
vraiment ils prennent des drogues
c'est vraiment une bête de scène c'est
pour ça qu'il faut les légaliser parce
que sinon ils font les pauvres vous
n'êtes vraiment pas d'accord alors c'est
vraiment une somme en une bête de sexe
vous dit quand j'ai comme un geste rare
et vous dites quand j'ai commencé mon
premier bouquin le jour j'ai commencé
mon premier bouquin qui s'appelle dans
ma chambre je les écris parce que je
savais plus quoi faire je mettais
branlée six fois est ce que tu es il
faut six fois dans la journée
demandez aux garçons à une fois dans
leur vie où ils sont mal et c'est quoi
ton rester simple dont record ouais rien
si fois c'est beaucoup quand même un bel
vraiment réagir à christine ses comptes
avec ses yeux tout ce que dit j'essaie
de faire un peu le
le portrait de guillaume dustan qui est
un écrivain important parce que si vous
comprenez il dit par exemple j'ai vu que
tout ça c'était l'enfer de dante et je
me suis jeté dedans
est ce que vous comprenez cette
attirance qu'on peut avoir pour un
certain type de boîte les backrooms 1 je
crois je crois qu'effectivement et on
peut avoir une certaine forme d'attirant
cette fascination jeu suivant
effectivement je comprends tout à fait
et je vous comprenez que parallèlement à
ça il peut y avoir un souci de sainteté
un souci de parallèlement à cette je
pense que oui sincèrement on peut le
croire je pense que c'est une erreur
mais je pense que la personne peut le
croire sincèrement l'âme
moi je pense que je suis plus vie
celui-là
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il ya à côté il ya
deux personnages sur ce plateau est vrai
que c'est fascinant et j'attends de voir
le pire mais la vague cuir c'est le
principe de cette émission c'est de
mettre ensemble sur la scène qui se
seraient pas rencontrés sans tout le
monde en parle mais comme il habite dans
le même pays à l'époque ça nous fait
plaisir c'est de faire se rencontrer en
espérant que en espérant qu'ils se
comprennent un peu et qu'ils discutent
vous n'êtes pas tendre avec les hétéros
1 vous dit qu'ils nous ont piqué notre
look à nous les homos ils nous ont piqué
le le soin du corps enfin je veux dire
vous n'êtes pas ne pas très tendre avec
1 1 quand je dis piqué moi je suis pour
que les bonnes idées circulent alors que
les hétéros phase à chaud ça génial
oui ça super jeudi reproduite et les
eaux les hétéros par exemple ils rêvent
de l'iref de baiser comme nous mais moi
je crois pas du tout à la différence
déjà hétéros homos tout ça j'y crois pas
hétéro homo j'y crois pas en fameux j'y
crois pas ça c'est de céder c'était
catégorique on pas de sens moi je suis
homosexuel mais ton avec deuxième parce
que j'aime les hommes pas et j'aime pas
les hommes qui se prennent pour des
femmes par exemple du tout du tout du
tout dont vous parlez vous souvent là au
féminin vous dites oui aujourd'hui je
suis wigan par exemple oui parce que
mais parce que je veux pas qu'on croie
qu'il a les
hommes et les femmes je trouve sa source
est extrêmement mutilant pour l'être
humain à être humain il est beaucoup
plus divers que ça si on laisse les gens
s'exprimer ils font un tas de choses qui
sont entre ces deux caricatures france
et franchement cdc ridicule très bien
pourtant ce qui est incroyable chez
guillaume dustan c'est qu'au départ dans
la vie
vous avez plutôt commencé normalement
vous avez fait sciences po
j'ai fait reynard 1 du team magistrats à
versailles c'était comment quand vous
étiez magistrats à versailles j'allais
très bon pote
ouais non c'est vrai enjeu en plus se
placer un couplet sur les fonctionnaires
ça a été rude
ben fonctionnaires c'est l'horreur moi
je suis vraiment pour que ça cesse parce
que on commence on n'aime pas le système
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'on est
obligé d'appliquer plein de drague
l'affreuse qui tue tout le monde et puis
donc on se révolte un peu mais la
machine est tellement puissante qu'au
bout d'un moment on fait comme tous les
fonctionnaires c'est-à-dire que vous
nous emmerder les gens qui viennent dans
les trucs et on vous roucas donc on dit
à mes champs offshore que quand on veut
bien fonctionné on bien méchant ça fait
partie des malédictions du monde actuel
il faut changer alors en 90 100 90 2 les
découvertes que vous étiez séropositifs
et à ce moment là vous changez de nom
vont changer de vie voilà c'est à savoir
si la tendance est plus tard ça oh non
je me suis rasé la tête en 88 ans 90
positif j'ai envie en 95
oui vous avez vécu cinq ans magistrat
séropositives sans changer de vie oui
vous avez bien choisi de publier sous un
pseudonyme
oui mais allez je voulais pas perdre mon
boulot je m'accroche je voulais pas même
temps vous vous dites je vais détruire
l'ordre social donc je comprends
toujours pas c'est progressif si vous
voulez moi je me rendais pas compte
j'étais un peu comme si mme boutin je me
rendais pas compte que l'ordre social
il est mauvais et qui cassent l'être
humain voilà elle ne se rend pas compte
de ça mais je pense qu'elle va elle va y
arriver
ça va venir si on veut résumer on
pourrait dire que quand guillaume dustan
était petit pensez que c'est lui qui
avait un problème et depuis qu'il a
grandi il a découvert que c'était le
monde qui avait un problème je crois
qu'on peut le résumer ça comme ça alors
maintenant merci guillaume dustan vous
restez avec nous donc comme il s'appelle
nicole comportementaliste un petit peu
oui on vous a comparé à bret easton
ellis mais plutôt ce qui est plutôt un
compliment non la politique de patchwork
entre à la fois ça va de votre contrat
et votre éditeur jusqu'au 15 et rouge de
votre de votre grand-mère m'enfin c'est
vrai que c'est moderne
guillaume du store
comment ça va super je suis pas encore
mort savard est toujours en vie c'est
déjà pas mal ah ouais guillaume dustan
le père de la morandais natasha st-pier
emmanuel philibert de savoie carignan
laurent baffie
voilà guillaume dustan auteurs éditeurs
et vous publiez d'ailleurs chez balland
dans la collection que vous dirigez qui
s'appelle le rayon un livre qui
s'appelle génie divin mais comment on
fait
je comprends pas que dire falco le fasse
et que vous ne fassiez pas il faut
savoir déplaire balladur l'a fait rocard
l'a fait je ne le fais pas raison jean
paul ii l'a fait non bien le faire bien
sûr alors commence très fort votre
bouquin guillaume dustan vous parlez de
renaud camus qu'est cet écrivain qui
dans son journal intime publié chez
gallimard l'année dernière se plaignait
qui est trop de juifs dans une émission
qui s'appelle panorama sur france
culture et vous page 12 du bouquin sert
dès le début vous dites attention je ne
suis pas renaud camus je suis pire donc
via les directs hausse dans la provoc
pourquoi parce que d'abord moi je peux
me le permettre parce que je suis juif
donc oui c'est plus facile pour attaquer
les juifs quand on est juste enfin on a
le droit d'attaquer juste que quand on
est juif donc prend moins de risques
c'est clair c'est ça et c'est vrai
d'ailleurs page 102 votre bouquin vous
donnez votre cv complet est
effectivement vous donnez votre vrai nom
william barranais expliqué que vous êtes
juifs sépharades et ashkenazes mélanger
et donc le fait d'être juif vous
autorise à dire ce que vous dites page
26 avouait toute une litanie sur kilmer
kilmer kilmer j'en attends qu il marre
on attend qu'il en attend patiemment
n'attend que ça se passe le fait des
juifs vous autorise à surenchérir sur
renaud camus
ben moi je fais pas exactement pour les
mêmes raisons on sert que
lui l'a taclé juifs en disant ils sont
pas françaises n'ont pas de racines et
moi je dis les juifs en ce moment ont
une espèce de magistère moral sur la
france et puis je pense l'occident en
général mais bon beaucoup la france
voilà restreint à la france parce qu'on
leur demande de sauver le judéo
christianisme si vous voulez dans la
mesure où le christianisme s'est
discrédité c'est vrai que plus personne
là l'église à part les gens de plus de
60 ans c'est ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure vous disiez tout à l'heure avec
des vieux je suis pas là pour polémiquer
pourquoi pardon je vois pas pourquoi
vous parlez pas vexer polémiquer avec
vous je souhaiterais continuer parce que
devrait continuer à raconter mon trio
pour bien mince au point commun d'accord
mais enfin vous dit que les juifs exerce
aujourd'hui en occident à magistère
moral parce qu'on leur demande de sauver
le judéo-christianisme parce que le
christianisme s'est discréditée ouais
oui je vous vois pas en quoi m'enfin bon
606 est discréditée au sens où plus
personne n'a envie de faire ce que fait
le pas pour ça qu'on va faire alors
allez-y allez-y alors non mais expliquez
votre jauge calmement cpcpc paramount
est ce un peu sympa un constat quoi je
me lapp a largué que j'ai glissé en vue
du faux menons à ce que je constate
c'est que les gens les plus intéressants
dans dans je vais être horrible mais qui
ont moins de 35 ans ils vont pas
l'église ils vont pas aux jmj
ils vont plutôt en rêve et en boîte de
nuit où elle est recalée deux ça allait
vraiment il n'ya pas les 2 hommes et 2
millions giorgi a logiquement fait mais
c'est la règle dans la vie des gens qui
devraient prendre d ecstasy au lieu de
30 des hosties effective pourquoi devoir
parce que l'ecstasy strata très bien
mais pas de terrorisme là dessus les
chais la liberté au jour
bien jean pas l'air d'accord les jeunes
dernier ils connaissent rien et bien on
continue c'est quand balladur parle à
tout le monde c'est vrai que j'avais vu
quand même ce balladur il a un magistère
moral or lui pour le coup donc dans ce
cv qui est pas chante votre bouquin vous
donnez votre date de naissance 1965
vous parlez de votre homosexualité vous
parlez des livres que vous avez écrit
alors pourquoi je comprends pas avant
qu'on vous racontiez votre vie quand
vous donnez votre cv
vous disiez que vous avez fait l'ena ce
qui est pas mal et que après vous
allaitez juge
pourquoi dans ce cv là vous oubliez ça
vous le vous le rayer de votre vie cette
période l'ena juge administratif non
benzema différents roman qui raconte que
tu as été à l'ena je me suis dit bon je
garde ça pour la prochaine fois ouais
non parce que vous avez fait le concours
général sciences po l'ena quand même
c'est pas mal j'ai été juge à tahiti
parce qu'à l'époque j'ai dit que vous
étiez séropositifs
vous avez décidé de fuir paris et ça
d'un seul coup c'est ça ne fait plus
partie de votre biographie bien à part
ça le cv quand même juste sur un certain
nombre de points
vous habitez le marais pour que vous
pouvez pas habiter dans et et rolande
vous êtes obligés d'habiter dans le
ghetto ben c'est pas loin de mon travail
à pied si vous vouliez quand même déjà
un avantage
et à part ça je trouve que ouais quand
on rentre dans le marais 11 et qu'on
voit des pda moi je me dis voilà ça y
est c'est des gens qui vivent et
ailleurs je le sens - quoi penser que le
pdci n'a plus que les hétéros ben je
concevais pas les [ __ ] et spécial parce
que tout le monde sait qu'ils baissent
beaucoup plus quoi déjà et c'est quand
même très important dans la vie quoi le
plaisir
mais sans politique alors vous êtes dont
vous dites que vous êtes éditeur
écrivain a levé 18 mille francs par mois
et alors maintenant venons en au fond du
bouquin vous dites c'est votre thèse
vous dites on se croit libre
c'est faux il ya toujours des
oppresseurs et des opprimés
il ya toujours des bourreaux et des
victimes le monde est toujours homophobe
raciste patriarcal sexistes autoritaire
family ariste théocratique classiste et
c'est donc finalement pour vous quand on
dit 68 a permis une certaine
libéralisation de la société que pour
vous ce rien n'a changé en fait non non
non je pense qu'on on a avancé mais je
pense qu'il ya eu un énorme retour en
arrière et et on sait très bien il ya
des dates
moi je pense que la cassure elle s'est
passé en 1975 quand giscard a remonté
les champs elysées en pull je crois
qu'il a pu en pull pour montrer qu'il
était cool et en fait tout le monde ait
changé il y avait des films pornos et
tous partout et donc toutes les télés
ont montré le défilé du 14 juillet avec
le président de la république et suce
moi pour ma tout mouillé aux
pénétrations par les trousses
vous partez maintenant c'est choquant à
écouter ça quand même non
et alors et bah ça a donné lieu à une
espèce de levée de boucliers de l'ordre
moral c'est-à-dire le bon je sais pas
quand le lendemain à l'assemblée
la droite et la gauche puritaine de
l'époque se sont alliés pour dire on
peut pas permettre aux français d'être
libres 1 qu'ils arrêtent ils vont tous
voir des films où il ya des actes
sexuels que l'église chrétienne nous a
dit qu'il fallait pas faire donc on va
mettre fin à tout ça et on va voter une
loi 75 pour vous c'est là le retour en
arrière c'est le début deux de ses
débuts tout ce qu'on est en train de
voir finir maintenant parce que je pense
que là on va vers autre chose
non mais il a choisi un créneau provoc
je vais pas les décors way maintenant
j'arrive à dur alors votre bouquin vous
fait l'état de vos combats habituel
usage récréatif des drogues donc on y
arrive à vous il faut vous disions de
dépénaliser l'anc la gauche ne légalise
pas la drogue
toutes les drogues il n'y a pas de
gauche c'est ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement jospin
je peux toujours l'attendre ouais usage
récréatif des drogues dérèglement des
sens
alors vous dites tout le monde a envie
de se faire attacher fister godet
fouetter partouzer bouffer du sperme
mais les gens ne le font pas parce
qu'ils ont peur mais ça c'est l'évidence
mais c'est pas du tout de ces pas du
tout
et si c'est pas du tout de dérèglement
des sens qu'il s'agissait simplement de
d'expérimenter la vie ouais c'est tout
il faut expérimenter la vie voilà la
plupart du temps on ne permet pas parce
qu'on a été dressé depuis tout petit
avec ce qu'on nous dit c'est à dire pas
jouer avec son caca et tous ces trucs là
déjà ça commence mal à partir de ce
moment là en janvier réédition l'hiver à
part la grille puis je vais avoir la
griffe pour vraiment expérimenté laviec
ouais c'est ça que vous fermez mais il
faut que vous l'avez expérimenté vous
continuez à le faire nous aimer ça non
justement me viendrais dans le temps
quoi messi me suis très content d'avoir
fait donc là vous avez tous fait là
attaché
fister godet fouetter
partout j'ai bouffé du sperme d'étouffer
la tendance c'est ce que disait à
l'aborder comme un moment c'est bien peu
comme une drogue non non les est
cependant d'une sexualité exacerbée
non ça ne devient pas comme une drogue
c'était comme une drogue ouais c'était
comme une drogue et je m'en suis libéré
ouais ça va mieux là ben phu et enfin
t'as pas l'air
non
alain moins de pair avec mon père en
même temps il a fait l'ena
moi je trouve ces deux énarques les plus
sympas que je connais pas ce qu a connu
d'autres qui sont moins drôle
voilà c'est quand même pour un mec qui a
fait l'ena je trouve qu'il a bien sûr
mais au final je lui demande roman est
beaucoup plus chili c'est vrai autre
combat de guillaume dustan baiser sans
capote
oui alors vous vous êtes séropositif
vous baiser entre séropositifs au moins
quand même j'aimerais bien mais ma
personne veut coucher avec moi parce que
j'ai trop connu maintenant alors ça va
être très embarrassant mais l'embarqué
danger là pourquoi parce que pourquoi
parce que l'on n'est pas c'est une façon
de attendait c'est intéressant ça c'est
une façon de punir votre célébrité
il est tellement connue bahreïn pour
l'emmerder je vais pas couché avec lui
c'est ça bah ouais ouais
cette histoire de baiser sans capote là
guillaume c'est quand même important je
veux dire vous êtes d'accord avec jean
paul ii vomir et d'une certaine façon
mais sauf que vous c'est quand même bien
il ya un côté un paradoxe
il ya un côté sympa mais il ya quand
même un côté cyril collard quand même
quelque part c'est à dire c'est un
revolver cluj aidé entre les jambes
quand même non c'est un vrai bonheur que
j'ai entre les gens tout le monde a un
revolver dans la tête un front je veux
dire la vie c'est ce à quoi s'est il ya
un risque de violence en libye c'est
vrai et et moi ce que je demande c'est
simplement qu'on m'empêche pas d'avoir
une sexualité normale avec des gens qui
ont le même statut sérologique que moi
et vous dites d'ailleurs le coup de
génie divin ça reprend le titre de votre
livre c'est d'avoir mis ce problème de
de baiser sans capote que vous appelez
le bareback sur le plan philosophique
c'est à dire que finalement c'est la
responsabilité
j'ai commencé quand même c'est comme un
devoir du bacon philo quoi moi ce que
j'ai dit c'est que
on est responsable pour soi et pas pour
les autres et ouais c'est un point
important parce que c'est effectivement
le contraire de ce que plein de gens
essayent de nous faire croire et je
pense que c'est très dangereux de penser
qu'on est responsable pour les autres
parce que à partir du moment où ça on
s'occupe plus de soi et puis se passe
plus rien quoi vous croyez que les
responsables pour soi et pour les autres
et pour le nom n'est pas responsable
non on peut les écouter les autres on
peut les écouter c'est vraiment la seule
chose qu'on peut faire là c'est déjà pas
mal
ah ben je fais beaucoup moins là on a un
point d'accord est-ce que alors pour
être beaucoup plus prosaïque
est ce que il n'ya pas qu'en vous baiser
sans capote avec des séropositifs est ce
qu elle pas un risque de surinfection ça
c'est son nom raconte pires toujours pas
prouvé
ouais et puis et puis même s'il y avait
un risque de surinfection
on a droit de prendre ce risque ouais
alors quand vous dites guillaume dustan
toute façon on meurt pas du sida
moi je suis séropositif depuis neuf ans
je suis toujours là
j'ai rien pris jusqu'à récemment une
bithérapie et tout ça c'est dans la tête
vous avez quand même pas peur de donner
un exemple un peu négatif un jeu jeff je
disais ça quand j'étais fou je disais ça
quand je pensais non mais sérieusement
on va les rassurer aujourd'hui on voit
que vous n'êtes plus fous n'est ce pas
je ne sais pas ouais voilà un nom je
disais ça quand je pensais que j'allais
à y passer parce que j'étais invincible
un gros délire quand même mais je pense
que dans des situations extrêmement
violente gens deviennent fous se
pourrait qu'ils sont fous dans la vie
c'est extrêmement il a alors là vous
savez comment ça va ouais mais ça va je
prends des médicaments je pense que je
vais mourir dans dix ans c'est pas très
agréable mais bon j'ai travaillé
beaucoup peut-être que dans dix ans de
réinventer achmed ouais ça m'aura pas
empêché le stress est un mage jeu bon
alors vous êtes favorable à l'euthanasie
oui bien sûr évidemment non je pense que
c'est la moindre des libertés que de
choisir sa mort
la position de l'église sur l'euthanasie
c'est quoi ces c'est de développer les
soins palliatifs pour éviter la
souffrance souffrance n'est pareil en
autriche moi je voyais à souffrir par
les eaux si elle déjà c'est sûr non on
pêche offrir si c'est un choix personnel
édition facile il souhaitait pas pour le
subir pour l'ebit et moi j'ai été très
impressionné parce que ma mère est morte
il ya un an elle a eu six mois de soins
palliatifs et nous l'avons accompagné
frères et soeurs chaque jour et je
trouve ce sont des étapes extraordinaire
pour connaître la personne jusqu'au bout
ou bien alors là où c'est plus grave
quand même guillaume page 274 vous
prenez l'eugénisme lite pour booster
l'intelligence il faut éliminer les gens
qui ont un quotient intellectuel
inférieur à 180 sinon on restera
toujours des singes ouais
voilà non mais je dis pas qu'il faut les
éliminer maintenant l'un d'eux ce qu'ils
soient d'accord
ça me rassure bastien c'est comme les
fonctionnaires si vous engagez d'accord
sur la maintenant on la garde
oui d'accord la série fonctionnaires on
attend qu'ils partent à la retraite quoi
c'est ça c'est la même chose tout qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec ceux qui vont naître
qui ont moins de 182 coach était là
c'est pareil on sera obligé de les
garder mais sinon mais là où là où c'est
un vrai débat c'est que ces mouches
telle intelligence ouais ouais si on
peut faut mettre le paquet ont
génétiquement pour améliorer l'espèce
humaine
c'est vrai qu'on a le content parce que
ça se voit les gens sont manipulés géré
les gens sont des gogos un gens sont des
victimes
voilà moi ça me fatigue en avance on
avance
alors vous en prenez à tout le monde
dans ce bouquin et puis alors ce qui m'a
le plus surpris même au [ __ ] vous dit en
fait les gens veulent toujours passer
pour le [ __ ] actif comme suit qui ne s'est
pas engueulé parce que finalement le
fait de passes faire [ __ ] des trains
p des actifs
ça rend un peu moins [ __ ] donc c'est mieux
que j'ai pas l'injure de base c'est quoi
c'est quand même [ __ ] ouais non moi je
suis pour qu'on criminalise les injures
homophobes
oui bien sûr je suis pas loin quand même
tant mieux parce que moi j'en ai marre
de vie dans un monde où j'entends paix d
[ __ ] tout le temps quand je me sens
visé laminaire lors d'it l'actif est mis
en valeur alors que le passif il est
considéré comme une [ __ ] basse et
l'homme il est mis en valeur et la femme
qu'ils considéraient comme un william un
candidat de merlin donc ça veut dire
qu'il ya un machisme homo finalement ce
que je dis c'est que les rapports de
pouvoir dans l'humanité changeront pas
tant que les hommes vivront pas leur
homosexualité naturel et que donc ils se
feront pas [ __ ] par d'autres messieurs
comme eux parce que ce jour-là ils
comprendront les phares il ne méprisons
plus voilà c'est tout retrouvez pas que
votre dialogue est un peu
exhibitionniste passé des choses que
j'entends confession en confidence mais
quel intérêt
on attendait c'est la vie aujourd'hui
est de dominer la vie mais la vie on la
partage pas comme ça n'importe comment
si je suis pas d'accord avec vous
thibault cependant je pense qu a pas de
raison que les choses doivent être dites
et que ce qui fait la force de cette
émission si justement qu'on parle de
tout tout à fait librement tous est
intéressant dans une télévision qui est
très con passé qui est très fermée sur
elle même je trouve intéressant au moins
une fois par semaine le samedi soir de
pouvoir tout dire je n'aurais je ne
crains pas d'accord et je ne crains pas
qu'on m'enlève d un monopole de
confidences oui mais ma question que je
me pose c'est le veut dire est-ce qu'on
peut tout dire en public quoi ça
mais une question se pose au public
d'ailleurs oui oui je pourrais y jouer
mais bon voilà c'est mon j'y réfléchirai
c'est mon côté 68 peut-être alors page
254 et pour finir vous défendez la femme
car vous dit j'étais impuissant pendant
un an j'ai donc passif pendant un an et
c'est un sale boulot de ce fait remettre
son pouvoir rendre la pareille donc si
vous êtes assez féministe une certaine
façon y'a pas pu me ce que moi ouais
d'ailleurs ça se voit que tout ça se
voit pas ce que je porte les stigmates
de la féminité c'est christ et qu'on
perd et ouais le blasphème est pas
mais quoi
guillaume dustan je pense que pour vous
une interview psi serait assez bienvenu
on ne bouge pas pendant le single on ne
bouge pas pendant qu' on ne bouge pas
pendant le d'hier
[Applaudissements]
bien l'interview psy est ce que vous
êtes mytho j'ai peur vous soyez tous là
j'ai peur j'ai peur que vous ayez géreur
que vous ayez une croix dans chaque cas
allez courage bah non non je veux me
c'est pas plutôt non je suis vraiment le
meilleur écrivain de france voilà donc
germé galop vous êtes les galops vous le
reconnaissez
non j'ai le sens de ma valeur d'accord
est ce que vous êtes parano extrêmement
mais je pense que j'ai vraiment de
bonnes raisons de l'être
pourquoi parce que tout le monde n'en
veut pas du tout on attend tous les cas
pas moi le gentil
est ce que vous êtes schizo bas c'était
quand je me rends compte c'est trop tard
si vous êtes maso oui non vous n'avez
pas souffrir non gelée était
cliniquement 1
mais je suis plus quoi parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé
c'est très difficile à soigner est ce
que vous êtes sado depuis que je suis
plus masos chez des opportunités pour
l'être et j'essaie de résister je m'en
passe vous êtes saudeau oui évidemment
est ce que vous êtes rocco
ben non malheureuse gros lolos non
j'aimerais lire parce que les pdg les
oreilles mon père mais machin je suis
bien refoulé c'est à dire que
voilà c'est que depuis qu'elles s'y là
comme je trouve que c'est vraiment trop
trop trop trop lourd pour moi de coucher
avec une femme parce que c'est risqué
magna
j'ai plus jamais nos relations et les
femmes alors que s'il n'y avait pas ça
je pense que ça m'arrive de temps en
temps donc vous pourriez être gros lolos
en fait ouais le vibro je fais ça depuis
des années triaud moi j'aime plutôt 4 et
plus géronto géorgiens dont le sort est
avec moi exhibo sens de la mode c'est
est ce que vous êtes de sa mode est ce
que vous êtes travail en compte
l'otage si vous êtes travelo non est ce
que vous êtes adamo oui complètement
bayer là
cette semaine
pas toutes les semaines et d'amour de
temps en temps vous l'aurez de temps en
temps et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de inhabituel abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou